notre invité politique ce matin c'est
david cormand bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés
européens vente d'europe écologie les
verts vous êtes avec nous pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour cristal bertrand
jorian bonjour david cambon journaliste
elle du groupe la dépêche
on commence on va parler environnement
climat avec vous david cormand le haut
conseil pour le climat jugent que les
efforts de la france pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique sont
toujours insuffisants pour respecter ses
objectifs mais il reconnaît quand même
qu'à une baisse des émissions françaises
de co2 qui s'est accentuée en 2019
est ce que c'est la preuve que le
gouvernement se donne quand même les
moyens pour le climat pour vous non vous
avez une lecture bienveillante c'est
tout à votre honneur des travaux du haut
conseil pour le climat en réalité les
raisons pour laquelle ça légèrement et
pas assez vite mais c'est en 2019 c'est
des raisons qui sont pas structurel et
conjoncturel notamment à divers très
doux et hélas on n'est pas sur la bonne
la bonne lancée en plus ici au sénat le
projet de loi climat résilience a été
revu encore à la baisse ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour pouvoir être en
dessous les 1,5 degré sur simplement
respecter les accords de paria il
faudrait baisser de 60 100 % en europe
et donc aussi en france nos rejets de
gaz à effet de serre à horizon 2030
l'union européenne a pas fait assez on
est soi disant à -55% net désole ainsi
un peu relou mais 55% est c'est pas
baisse de 55% à ce qu'on compte ce qu'on
appelle les puits de carbone pour
cambrai c'est une baisse de 52,8
il faudrait moins 65 donc déjà on n'est
pas assez et là avec ce cas modifier le
sénat on est à moins 30
donc on voit bien qu'on est à un rythme
qui n'est pas assez soutenu et je dis
pas ça c'est pas comme dans les autres
domaines
la question de l'environnement
oui on joue à madame ou monsieur plus
pourra plus le truc la nature elle
négocie pas soit les conditions
d'habitabilité de la terre sont réunis
soit ne le sont plus regardez ce qui se
passe aux états-unis au canada avec eux
des records de température bref on est
dans un moment de bascule de notre
civilisation et soit on à la prise de
conscience d'agir en conséquence
soit on continue sur une lancée qui
n'est pas suffisante
le sénat justement dit qu'il a modifié
le texte pour aller plus loin c'est vous
partagez pas cet avis non moi quand je
vois les travaux de mes collègues
écologistes qui ont un groupe désormais
au sénat qu'avait propos j'ai proposé un
projet de loi climat résilience
alternatif et bien c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont pas voté là ce qui c'est vrai c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans la bonne ligne et
ya des reculs sur si on recule les
échéances sire que sur les objectifs on
dit alors j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas
suffisant mais on pérore sur des
objectifs mais quand il s'agit de voir
ce qu'il faut faire concrètement on n'y
arrive pas c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit
le haut conseil pour le climat reporte à
plus tard il n'y a pas de mesure entre
guillemets contraignante c'est à dire
qu'ils font en sorte qu'il ya vraiment
des décisions qui sont suivies d'effet
c'est le cas de l'analyse du haut
conseil pour le climat et c'est le cas
aussi de l'analyse de du comité de
citoyens pour le climat où là aussi il a
seulement 10 % 10 % des propositions des
citoyens qui in fine et sont reprises
on est très loin de la promesse de
emmanuel macron 15 et 10 sans filtre et
146 propositions là le sénat par exemple
sur l'artificialisation des sols sur les
zones à faibles émissions sur les
éoliennes redonne la main aux
collectivités locales alors en dix ans
ce sera fait au plus près du terrain on
pourra faire de la dentelle et c'est pas
une bonne une bonne solution pour vous
alors ça paraît sympathique et
d'ailleurs certains points de vue ça
l'est sauf qu'en matière d'
artificialisation des sols si vous
donner le pouvoir à une commune
périurbaine qui a des difficultés de
perte d'habitants qu'à des difficultés
de pertes de recettes fiscales
la tentation pour autoriser un centre
commercial une nouvelle zone
pavillonnaire est énorme
c'est pourquoi
sous le gouvernement précédent on avait
fait passer toute la question
dp à lui des plans locaux d'urbanisme au
niveau intercommunal pour qu'il ya une
vision de bassin de vie sur comment fait
usage des terrains et donc ça permet de
protéger les terres agricoles ça me
permet de protéger les terres de
biodiversité les espaces naturels et de
plutôt concentré l'habitation quand il
faut en faire autour des axes de
transport en commun
donc là j'ai peur que cette décision je
comprends venant du sénat donc vu
clairement dans ce sont les maires des
quotidiens je comprends qu'ils aient
fait ça en matière de lutte contre
l'artificialisation je le crains qu'il y
ait beaucoup d'effets pervers c'est de 6
sur les éoliennes par exemple là aussi
ils ont redonné la main en l'air en
disant qu'il faut un droit de veto des
maires sur l'implantation des éoliennes
est ce que les oraisons est ce que vous
comprenez on sait que c'est un sujet qui
est beaucoup monté bras dans cette
campagne des régionales est ce que vous
comprenez l'inquiétude des français
qu'ils disent mais moi je veux pas
d'éoliennes à côté de chez moi je le
comprend d'autant mieux que en matière
de politiques énergétiques alternatives
comme l'éolien l'état n'a pas joué son
rôle
il faut mettre de l'ordre dans ses
histoires sur l'implantation des
éoliennes sur terre la décision qui a
été prise changera pas le problème parce
que quand vous allez voir ce qui se
passe
la mairie qui est concerné par
l'implantation d'éoliennes elle est pour
parce que c'est des recettes etc c'est
les communes autour qui ne sont pas pour
donc c'est pas par ce moyen qu'on va
empêcher une forme d'anarchie dans
l'implantation des éoliennes
c'est en mettant des plans
d'implantation d'éoliennes qui soit
claire et c'est surtout en associant les
habitants les collectivités locales dans
des coopératives d'installation
d'éoliennes ou les bénéfices de
l'installation de l'éolienne revient aux
habitants du secteur et aux
collectivités du secteur aujourd'hui
sont des industriels qui arrive qui est
un peu
débauche des terrains pour le trouver
une implantation et ce en jouant ensuite
avec les profits donc c'est pas la bonne
méthode pour qu'ils aient une
acceptabilité deuxième élément en france
nous avons la deuxième façade maritime
du monde
vous savez combien d'éoliennes offshore
qui sont raccordés en a deux donc il ya
une charge sur l'éolien terrestre parce
que c'est le plus facile à faire
il faut développer dans une certaine
mesure mieux développer plus
qu'aujourd'hui
l'éolien offshore est ce que vous
entendez la grogne justement des
habitants parce que là vous parlez l'éco
mobilité qui disent c'est pas agréable
comme environnement se dément mais je
veux dire pourquoi j'entends ce qu'il ya
un an d'abord il faut être honnête avec
ça si on veut de l'électricité l'énergie
il faut bien la produire il n'existe pas
il n'existera jamais de mode de
production énergétique qui sont
indolores pour l'environnement et notre
qualité de vie produire de l'énergie en
consommer
ça implique des nuisances donc il faut
un débat démocratique sur quelles
nuisances
on accepte qu'on s'en est deuxième
élément c'est la sobriété dire qu'on
n'en parle jamais mais le premier sujet
c'est qu'on a un modèle de civilisation
qui considère que l'énergie en peul a
déjà dépensé de façon en toute impunité
la réalité c'est que c'est pas ça
deuxième sujet sur le pourquoi s'est
ressenti avec violence parce que souvent
ces éoliennes et les gens qui les
installent arrive un peu comme des
sauveurs sur des territoires qui sont
déjà oubliées depuis longtemps ont déjà
plein de route qu'ont déjà un paysage
des grains des les zones commerciales
des friches industrielles et
l'allégeance 10 mais c'est pas possible
c'est toujours sur nous que ça tombe il
ya ces véhicules comme un non seulement
un manque de respect mais une forme
d'humiliation de ces territoires et
celles et ceux qui vivent pour ça faut
le prendre en considération qu en
réalité aucun risque de fracture pour
vous un risque de fracture territoriale
si vous voulez les hauts lieux mais ça
fait très flou se surajoute un phénomène
global de métropolisation de la france
vous avez des territoires qui sont
avantagés au détriment de territoires
qui sont considérés comme périphérique
d'ailleurs on les appelle comme ça
qu'ils sont plus par les décideurs
politiques considérés comme des endroits
où on vit mais disons qu'on passe où on
fait les
ans d'âge des bouts de ddd des déserts
de fin des des stations d'épuration des
métropoles où on fait l'agriculture
intensive où l'on installe les zones
commerciales où on vire les entreprises
et autres trous avec des friches
industrielles comme je le disais donc là
pour moi les olim c'est un symptôme les
mandats manque de pensée l'égalité des
territoires à un mot sur ce qui se passe
au niveau européen les états membres de
l'union européenne qui ont approuvé
cette semaine une nouvelle loi climat
qui rend les objectifs de réduction de
gaz à effet de serre juridiquement
contraignant c'est une loi qui vise à
placer les climats au coeur de toutes
les décisions finalement de l'union
européenne est ce que ça veut dire que
l'union européenne est au rendez vous de
ces questions est non et non parce que
là encore il ya une déclaration
d'intention je cassais les pieds tout à
l'heure avec les chiffres des 55 65 50
de l'union européenne c'est ce que je
vous disais elle 10,55
il faudrait 65 ferons pour revenir à oui
mais c'est mieux parce qu'avant c'était
un wiimake s'est passé et cirque en fait
comme je vous le disais soit on réunit
les conditions pour rester en dessous
des 5%
si on fait 65 % de baisse en 2030 on à
66 % de chance je dis beaucoup trop de
pourcentage à 36 % de chances d'être en
dessous les 1,5 degré
s'ils ont fait 55 % de baisse on n'est
qu'à une chance sur deux d'être en
dessous de deux degrés vous voyez la
probabilité de rester en deçà des
chiffres dont on a besoin pour continuer
à habiter la terre c'est ça l'enjeu est
ce qu'elle est plus ce rendez vous que
les états membres en tout cas oui mais
le problème c'est qu'elle se donne pas
les moyens concrets d'agir je vais vous
donner un exemple la politique agricole
commune
dire que c'est la moitié du budget la
face et 40% du budget de l'union
européenne la politique agricole commune
est ce qu'on l'a changé de braquet en
matière de politique agricole commune
n'ont donc toujours pas l union
européenne se fixe des objectifs
mais quand il s'agit d'aller dans le
détail des choses est ce qu'on arrête le
gaz est ce qu'on arrête de financer les
infrastructures gazières et compris
celles qui sont déjà lancés est ce qu
ont même investi suffisamment pour faire
la transition énergétique est ce qu'on
s'aide pas trop sur le fait de pas de
maintenir des dérogations pour les
quotas carbone surtout ça on n'arrive
pas à le faire
est-ce qu'on fait une fiscalité juste
sur les transactions financières et
vincent le repousse à 2026 compliqué à
des déclarations toujours
rendre mais qui ne sont pas au rendez
vous du rythme dans lequel il faut agir
un dernier mot sur ces sujets avant de
parler des régionales avec crystal quand
vous expliquer que les états membres que
l'union européenne ne sera pas au rendez
vous que vous dites est ce que
finalement ils ne sont pas les coûts des
populations qui n'ont pas envie d'aller
plus vite au plus loin comment vous
sentez le marcheur japon reste encore
une fois pourquoi je ne crois pas parce
que regarder la convention citoyenne
pour le climat on a aboli au sort 150
citoyens qui était pas spécialement
écolo vous d'état lui disons les prêts
même ceux qui sont pas pressée les
lobbys c'est l'effort s'installer les
forces économiques dominantes qui on le
sait dicte bien trop souvent leurs
règles pas seulement à au niveau
européen au niveau national et même un
front national ça rit aussi si elles ne
veulent pas à changer suffisamment vite
il ya un deuxième obstacle c'est la
démocratie européenne ale inachevé quand
vous regardez ce que votre le parlement
européen
c'est plutôt plus ambitieux mais après
il ya un deuxième couperet qui sont les
états nations c'est le conseil c'est la
réunion des états qui elle sans ces
états ou des intérêts contradictoires et
il faut l'unanimité pour prendre ses
décisions et donc là vous avez un taquet
qui baisse une nouvelle fois et c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a pas voté à la fin
parce qu'une fois que conseil a discuté
de cette loi européenne sur le climat
ses revenus par leurs parlements il
avait encore ratiboiser les truites ok
mais je savais le sait les lobbys parce
qu'on l'a vu par exemple sur la taxe
carbone n'était pas les laumes il ya une
partie des français qui était content la
taxe carbone la sur les zones à faible
émission il ya des français qui disent
mais moi j'ai pas les moyens de changer
de voiture
voilà il va falloir que je fasse avec ma
voiture au diesel j'ai pas les moyens de
nous en faisons est-ce que c'est
uniquement les lobbys ou est-ce qu'il ya
pas une partie des français mais qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'appliquer une
politique écologique telle que vous la
traitez non alors d'abord vous avez
raison mais ce que les français
n'arrivent en plus les moyens
d'appliquer ces deux modèles actuels
c'est pas à cause de l'écologie que la
fracture énergétique facture énergétique
et la fracture d'ailleurs augmente c'est
pas à cause de l'écologie que les loyers
augmentent c'est pas à cause des de
l'écologie que les salaires baissent
qu'il ya une précarisation du travail
donc en réalité le vrai sujet ce qui
fait que c'est la vie
coûte de plus en plus cher c'est pas
l'écologie c'est l'absence d'écologie
c'est qu'on a conçu des infrastructures
on a conçu l'organisation d'un
territoire
on a conçu un modèle économique sur la
base d'une énergie bon marché illimitée
et sans conséquence pour l'environnement
or c'est exactement le contraire qui se
passe donc si on veut résoudre y compris
les problèmes de preuves de pouvoir
d'achat est l'exemple des gilets jaunes
est excellent et gilet jaune les gens
ont dit mais vous vous rendez pas compte
déjà toutes les dépenses imposées que
nous avons et nous si on prend la
voiture qu'on nous a encouragés à
acheter diesel pour aller au travail
c'est pas par plaisir aujourd'hui la
voiture c'est plus un outil de liberté
et sauf pour les très riches pour la
plupart des gens c'est une charge
c'est en moyenne 500 euros par mois pour
les gens qui ont vraiment une voiture
pourrie parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens
c'est 300 euros par mois c'est donc deux
smic plus de smicards en c1 13e et un
14e mois
écolo si on arrivait à faire approuver
les solutions agiles et ce qu est ce qu
a pas marché notamment avec le monde et
gilet jaune c'est le gouvernement a
quand même été gonflé il a fait une
fiscalité imposée et il n'a pas dit on
utilise cet argent pour vous libérer des
charges imposé vous avez sûr qu'on va
utiliser l'argent mais pour autre chose
notamment la réduction de charges pour
les entreprises c'est là qu'est
l'injustice comment on a quand même le
sentiment que le discours sur
l'environnement qui est votre discours a
du mal à passer
dimanche et le dimanche précédent vous
avez été victime comme les autres dans
taux d'abstention assez important est-ce
que vous avez dû me pas du mal à être
audible auprès des électeurs comme les
autres partis politiques alors que
l'urgence climatique vous le dit
et là est sans aucun doute vous avez
raison je pense que le premier
enseignement de ces dernières élections
c'est une claque
c'est une claque qui a été décerné à
l'ensemble de la classe politique
pourquoi rien à mon avis pourquoi j'ai
pas eu toutes les réponses mais parce
que les sujets qui ont été évoqués
pendant cette campagne n'était peut-être
pas les sujets qui en définitive
intéresser les françaises et les
français même par les représentants de
votre propre parti
on a eu du mal à avoir voix au chapitre
on a parlé beaucoup
la question de la sécurité de la
migration de la brutalité de la police
qui sont pas des compliments d'ailleurs
ni départementale ni régionale ou que sa
vue vous suivez c'est le dossier là nous
c'est vrai la hausse des raisons c'est
qu'on a eu du mal à imposer
comment dire une juste et hiérarchies
les thématiques et donc on a eu du mal à
imposer les thématiques écologiques
après on fait ce qu'on peut avec nos
petits bras musclés soit on a dit que la
pandémie justement rendait un peu plus
eu des bleus ces sujets willy
heureusement aujourd'hui vous le disais
il fait 50 degrés à vancouver on sent
bien que le sujet sur la table
pourquoi vous avez tant de mal à être
audible et parce que c'est dur et
dessine pas on n'est pas les seuls
prescripteurs des thématiques de
campagne qui peut y avoir après là où il
faut être juste c'est que entre 2015 et
la seule force politique a augmenté en
nombre de voix par rapport avec malgré
l'abstention record c'est les verts dire
que nous dans quasiment toutes les
régions sauf en occitanie on a augmenté
en nombre de voix alors que toutes les
forces politiques ont baissé en nombre
de voix celle qui était présente
évidemment à l'époque donc je n'arrivais
pas à aller plus loin et a remporté
vision c'est vrai mais personne on a
gagné des régions en tout cas en france
métropolitaine donc il ya eu une forme
de statu quo ça c'est vrai après on a
des progressions qui sont inédites
non seulement aux élections régionales
mais aussi aux élections départementales
ce qui est un bon signe parce que ça
pète ça c'est quand même marqueur d'une
implantation de l'écologie politique
dans les territoires qu'on avait pas
jusqu'à maintenant si vous me dites oui
mais c'est quand même par rapport aux
enjeux écologiques s'est quand même
passé parce que vous avez dit mais celle
de c vous devriez faire plus de voix je
ne peux qu'être d'accord avec vous après
on fait ce qu'on peut et malgré tout on
y arrive on arrive petit à petit a
comparé la question qu'on se pose on a
vu une nette progression lors des
municipales en de nouveau candidat des
villes ont été remportés de nombreuses
villes ar re veut que je les verts
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
marquer un peu le pas est ce que les
déclarations des différents maires
depuis les municipales n'ont pas pu
décevoir certains électeurs enfin en
tous les cas nous
raison de poser la question parce que
pour rien vous cacher je me pose est la
même et c'est pour ça que j'ai été voir
précisément l'eau score aux régionales
et aux départementales
là où nous avons gagné des villes et
dans quasiment toutes ces vies nous
sommes en tête sommes en tête à
strasbourg
nous sommes en tête à lyon à lyon où la
région rhône alpes auvergne a été gagné
2,20 points d'avancé sur la région par
laurent wauquiez est un lion nous sommes
en tête même à bordeaux on est devant on
n'est pas premier
mais on est devant l'ancien maire la
liste de l'ancien maire de bordeaux
alors qu'on ouvre en hausse et les
villes que je vous cite se met le plus
de temps je crois que toute la légende
selon laquelle enfin la légende pour
tout cas l'analyse qui était légitime
mais dire vers l'autre bien sûr bien sûr
et sans le vérifier
et en fait non et non seulement on a
fait des bons scores aux régionales mais
dans ces villes où on n'avait même pas
forcément gagné l'effet des bons scores
aux municipales on gagne à la régulière
sans accord des cantons on a fait une
razzia à lille à rennes
donc je crois pas à cela par contre ce
qui serait juste qu'il est juste de dire
c'est que si dans ces territoires la
l'écologie continue de s'implanter sur
le reste des territoires de ces régions
on a eu du mal à faire suffisamment pour
battre les sortants mais malgré tout on
progresse voilà j'essaie de voir le
verre qui a déjà verre à moitié plein un
autre des enseignements de ces
régionales c'est que vous avez eu du mal
à passer des alliances notamment avec le
parti socialiste
est-ce que
ça complique un peu la proche de la
présidentielle pour vous alors pardon de
vous corriger mais nous on n'a pas eu du
tout de malades affirme allianz quand
nous étions en tête non mais c'est
important quand nous étions devant nous
avons fait des alliances ceux qui n'ont
pas réussi à faire des alliances c'est
le parti socialiste quand vous et étant
taxées s'alliant se sont pas
concrétisées mois mais pas partout dans
trois régions il ya eu des alliances
notamment centre-ville de l'or en
bourgogne franche comté
d'accord c'est que avant site était
quasiment partout tant que ça c'est
quand même un fait politique c'est on
peut pas renvoyer dos à dos celui qui
est victime du rejet et celui qu'on est
l'auteur se serait pris quand même quand
vous voyez le score de carole delga en
occitanie café qui a été la présidente
la mieux élue près de 58% des voix alors
que pour le coup elle n'a pas fait
d'alliances avec les écologistes est ce
que ça pose pas question est-ce que ça
renforce pas quand même le tracé s'agit
dira carole delga a fait une très bonne
campagne efficace à notre détriment
et elle a gagné largement et je vous dis
il ya une chose qu'il faut regarder au
delà des pourcentages
c'est carole delga entre 2015 et 2021 au
deuxième tour elle a perdu deux cent
mille voix c'est-à-dire 20%
les nombres de wasquehal avait fait en
2015 l'émirat occupé mais l'instance y
ont augmenté mais quand même c'est
compliqué de dire qu'une force politique
que le candidat est en dynamique
quand elle part quand elle perd 20% de
l'électorat la mandature d'avant
meilleur a gagné
y a pas de sujet là dessus après dans
d'autres régions comme en bretagne on
dit que la bretagne a été gagné par le
parti socialiste
au moment où nous parlons ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui le président sortant
socialiste de la bretagne
il n'a pas de majorité pour se faire
élire au parlement de bretagne
oui les choses sont un peu plus non
c'est que ça veut dire quoi que vous
serez est potentiellement une force de
blocage en bretelles en attendant les
bonnes force de blocage non
fusionner négocier point par point
pendant tout le mandat
dire non de deux choses l'une soit le
président sortant ne peut pas être
président sans nous et donc s'il fait un
accord avec nous c'est pas une région
socialistes c'est une région socialiste
et verte soit il se passe de nous il
fait plutôt à mon avis comme il en a
l'intention avec l ère où m et dans ce
cas là c'est plus une région socialistes
si une ccnr régions socialistes majorité
présidentielle donc venir dans les jours
qui viennent les cheveux mais au-delà de
ces questions là par rapport à votre
question initiale est une question très
importante sur la capacité d'alliance
moi je constate aujourd'hui que le parti
socialiste a percé perdu en capacité de
centralité capacit centralité sur le
fond politique
on voit bien que il ya des forces
contraires au sein du parti socialiste
avec d'un côté monsieur melon qui
appelle à voter pour valérie pécresse en
ile de france
madame des le gars qui dit les écologie
c'est très bien mais moi je le faire
tout seul
j'ai pas besoin d'eux et d'autres avec
qui ça se passe très bien dans la région
normandie on a fait dès le premier tour
derrière un parti socialiste on a des
bonnes relations
donc ça c'est un problème et en quoi
vous vous avez gagné en capacité de
centralité est ce que vous entendez
aujourd'hui les socialistes qui disent
ben on a gagné des régions s'est à
nouveau en tout cas on a conservé les
nôtres ils en ont gagné en outre-mer
quand même et c'est à nous du coup de
porter la voix de la gauche à la
présidentielle comment vous allez
contrer ça mais moi je ne cherche pas la
contrée le parti socialiste est un parti
qui a le droit d'avoir une candidature à
la présidentielle mais pardon c'est pas
moi qui depuis un an dire qu'il faut
s'unir il faut s'unir
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle olivier
faur aussi en politique j'aime bien la
constance moi j'étais aujourd'hui je
suis écologiste suis pas socialiste je
suis écologiste avant d'être de gauche
mes valeurs c'est celle de l'écologie je
respecte la gauche bien sûr son histoire
humanisme et je pense que ce qu'il faut
21e succès une nouvelle matrice qui
s'appelle l'écologie politique et donc
je suis très content on a tu es tu là je
demande aux socialistes déjà si les
sociale je me pose socialistes
écologistes
je suis jamais est-ce que vous
accepteriez vous que le candidat
écologiste se range derrière un candidat
ce serait ça n'a pas de sens nous on
sent que ça n'a pas de sens c'est
pourquoi c'est aux socialistes de se
ranger derrière quand il jouait deux
minutes se ranger derrière nous donc y
aura pas de candidature des fonds ce
qu'ils ont à faire moi ce que j'aime
c'est la clarté est d'ailleurs
l'abstention qu'on a vécu montre cela il
ya soixante-six pour cent des gens qu'on
pas été votée pourquoi un g10
le climat politique délétère fait que ça
donne pas tellement envie d'aller voter
et de y avait un manque peut-être de
clarté dans les os x politique qui était
fait donc moi je suis pour la clarté on
les écologistes proposent un projet
écologiste mais un rafistolage
d'alliance entre des gens qui ne veulent
en définitive pas travailler ensemble
c'est ce que nous a enseigné le parti
socialiste entre les deux tours des
régionales
d'un côté ils disent on veut candidature
commune le côté ils disent on veut pas
se mettre avec vous c'est lui la
dernière question sur la primaire des
écolos cristal c'est ça une question sur
la vie interne de votre parti donc eric
piolle devrait pousser peut-être déjà
déclarés pendant que nous parlions à la
primaire d'europe écologie les verts
delphine batho et yannick jadot retarde
visiblement leur déclaration de
candidature est ce que cette primaire a
du plomb dans l aile est ce que ou pas
non ouais la review il aura lieu elle
aura lieu au plein de raisons d'abord
aucune candidature à la candidature de
s'impose naturellement
donc il est normal dans un formations
politiques démocratiques que le choix se
fasse non seulement par les militantes à
8o mais vous savez que ça sera une
désignation qui sera ouverte tant que
toutes les personnes qui nous écoutent
qui nous regardent qui souhaitent y
participer pourront s'inscrire froide
ces deux euros pour pouvoir choisir
quelle candidature il souhaite voir
porter l'écologie politique
moi je pense qu en démocratie c'est une
bonne chose de faire comme ça je pense
que c'est normal mais vous savez que les
verts on nous bloque parfois à cause de
ça sont très attachés à cette démocratie
y compris leur démocratie interne et
donc non je n'y a aucune raison qu'on
fasse autrement parce que c'est juste de
faire comme ça et je me refuse mais qui
vaut dans cette primaire et moi je me
réjouis de la candidature d'erik cole et
lors de ses deux premières je voterai
pour lui je pense que c'est un candidat
solide sérieux il a montré qu'il était
capable de faire gagner l'écologie sur
une ligne claire a grenoble il a montré
qu'en plus les habitantes et les
habitants étaient satisfaits puisqu'ils
étaient très largement réélu aux
dernières municipales et je pense qu'il
correspond à une personnalité dont on a
besoin dans le temps politique
un peu plus sur les questions de terrain
pas péremptoire c'est pas c'est pas la
politique instagram quoi c'est la
politique concrète donc un dernier un
dernier rapidement puisque anne hidalgo
m et sa candidature à la présidentielle
sur les rails vers une tribune d'élus
est ce qu'elle a réussi à la faire
l'alliance socialiste écologiste à paris
est ce que ça serait une bonne candidate
que vous pourriez soutenir non non parce
que elle veut dit pas souvent mais anne
hidalgo et socialiste moi j'ai rien
qu'en une fois j'ai rien contre les
socialistes et les socialistes c'est
juste je pense une nouvelle aide sociale
écologie pour nom je pense que la social
démocratie ne correspond plus aux femmes
n'est plus une réponse aux enjeux du 21e
siècle
et par ailleurs il vous a pas échappé
dargaud et les écologistes à paris c'est
quand même un peu plus que compliqué
donc c'est compliqué de se mettre
derrière quelqu'un qui considère que
nous serions ambiguë par exemple avec la
république il faut être cohérent dans
les vignes merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin merci beaucoup
c'est celle
[Musique]